As a German, there would always be Nutella in our house,
and every time it would run low,
a new jar would magically appear.
So today I decided to introduce my husband to the concept of Nutella
and crepes.
I started by roasting my hazelnuts in the oven for about 10 minutes,
letting them cool slightly before rubbing them to get all the skin off.
I then transferred them over to my food processor
and let that go until they turned into a very shiny paste.
This point I added in my melted chocolate,
some cocoa powder,
vanilla, a pinch of salt, and some powdered sugar,
turn my food processor back on
and let that go while drizzling in some neutral oil.
Once that all came together, I put it aside,
let it cool slightly,
and that was our homemade Nutella.
I moved on to making my crepe batter by adding some eggs,
milk, water,
vanilla, a pinch of salt,
whisking that while I gradually added in some flour,
making sure that there's no clumps,
and also some melted butter.
I heated up my pan and my batter in
before spreading it as thin as I could.
Once my crepes were golden brown,
I folded them up and drizzled them with some of my homemade Nutella.
When my husband tried them, he was shocked at how good they were.